en canadá en las américas café el castor
cibernético la emisión de la sección en
español de radio cada canadá
internacional que les renovamos cada
semana a través de diversas vías como
ustedes saben nos pueden seguir y se
pueden unir a nosotros a través de
facebook live donde encuentran nuestro
programa cada viernes también a través
de nuestro sitio en internet www r6 net
punto sea donde el programa se encuentra
poco después del mediodía de cada
viernes y permanece allí cada sábado
todo el fin de semana efectivamente y no
se olviden que también cuentan con el
canal de youtube en donde nos pueden
seguir y donde hay cada vez más público
cada vez más seguidores cada vez más
amigos de éste cada vez más y más
empresas
y hoy estamos aquí en el estudio
rufo valencia que tal lujo un placer
estar con ustedes y siguiendo trata de
crecer ojos
desde la pantalla de un televisor con un
material muy importante que no hay que
perder para los barrios muchísimas
gracias luis laborda yo afortunadamente
me tocó el lugar en que te tengo a ti de
frente y la pantalla la habitación y
además acá con nuestra invitada al lado
también señor bueno yo soy luis laborda
hoy no está leonardo gimeno con nosotros
lo reemplaza al que va a ayudarnos en la
cuestión de facebook y todo lo que tiene
que ver con la técnica allí a través de
nuestro sitio en internet y por supuesto
en esta emisión hay un tema que va a
estar omnipresente por decirlo de alguna
manera que es el campeonato mundial de
fútbol que ya comenzó en rusia ayer se
llevó a cabo la ceremonia de
inauguración y el primer partido en la
ciudad de moscú y allí los locales
vencieron por 5 a 0
arabia saudita en un partido que no tuvo
alto vuelo técnico fantástico
a mí también me encantaron ellas me
parecieron muy buenos goles
toque el adversario arabia saudita
digamos que le faltaba más garra como
diríamos en américa latina pero los
goles fueron buenos así que tampoco
tiene gran experiencia y mundiales así
que vamos a del fútbol es decir casi nos
va a pisar fútbol durante toda esta
emisión pero vamos a ir por orden porque
tenemos como decía pablo una invitada
aquí en el público ya conoce a partir de
una entrevista que hizo tiempo atrás
para luego más barrios se trata de
susana ochoa vega que es sobre todo
dijiste que se está imponiendo sommelier
sí exactamente en españa decimos
sumilleres humillar pero ya se está
imponiendo sommelier porque al oído
es que no todas las personas pueden
catar qatar es
probar el vino analizar el vídeo
y cuál es la diferencia con el psoe a
grosso modo tienes el lama tiene
entendido
todos somos los vividores pero no
entendido significa todos
[Aplausos]
ese y todos usan estuviste nos vas a
comentar entre otras cosas dos eventos
en particular uno es la elección del
mejor sommelier de américa que se llevó
a cabo hace muy poquito aquí en la
ciudad de montreal del 22 del 22 al 24
de marzo ese es uno de los eventos de
los que vamos a hablar contigo pero
además acaba de volver y me dijiste que
venía directamente desde el aeropuerto
porque retornar en méxico donde se llevó
a cabo la segunda edición de hoy
nación - nación de animación de vivir
que de qué se trata este último evento
fíjate que es un evento la segunda vez
que lo hacen el año pasado no se pudo
porque fue el temblor
y es un recurso un reconocimiento al
vino mexicano hay entregas de premios a
vinos mexicanos que ganaron medallas en
el concurso de bruselas el año pasado en
méxico en guanajuato de hecho y tiene
buena calidad el vino mexicano
las veces que he estado en lugares poco
turísticos y los vinos mexicanos sean
estaban como arabia saudita en el
mundial bueno es verdad es verdad
nuestra cultura mexicana no tiene tanto
de tanta historia como la francesa por
ejemplo empezamos tranquilamente la
cultura del vino o sea está hablado
desde hace unos años contra 60 años no
más que eso no más que eso
si empezamos como vinos ligeros yo
considero que porque el paladar latino
así lo pide como hemos hablado como
hemos picoso condimentado y entonces lo
equilibramos con más dulce o sea no es
schlicher un ratito en mexicana sí pero
para que vinos tengo tequila
después del vino entonces los
latinoamericanos consumimos vinos vida
nos empezamos empezamos a consumir vinos
empezamos así con vinos de iniciación
para empezar a
educar el paladar porque nos tenemos que
hacer un paladar entonces si un latino
que quiere conocer el vino y empieza con
un vino bien corsé bien poderoso
no le van a lastimar pero no le va a
gustar el sabor la sensación de
astringencia de que esté seco bueno no
me gusta está muy fuerte
normalmente decimos eso susana quisiste
así en esta edición de coordinación de
vinos crisis técnico el cual fue el rol
que cumplir todo si uno se acude al
evento y dos fui a conocer 85 bodegas 85
horas que estaban ahí presentes y de
verdad que bonita sorpresa me quedé
fascinada por la instalación para
empezar una instalación grande y bien
airada
y además la decoración
fue en el hipódromo de las américas en
la ciudad de mexico entonces pues estaba
muy muy muy grande y sin embargo todo lo
cubrieron de piso de madera
como aquí lo tenemos el piso y si igual
tal cual estructuras de lonas blancas al
exterior tenemos hasta valet parking y
una lona negra al interior y entonces
cada quiosco estaba decorado con un muro
de ramas naturales entonces se veía bien
bien bien bonito ya la vista ya te había
ganado nunca había visto yo en los
salones los sommeliers y los meseros que
estaban ahí apoyándonos
bien trajeados de blancos todos
elegantísimos y cada kiosco tenía sus
propias copas de vidrio y si no no aquí
verdaderamente en méxico fue el altar
idealmente sería mejor el cristal que el
vidrio o no cambia gran cosa en lo que
respecta al vino como tal pues el
cristal ya no se usa mucho porque por la
cantidad de plomo que contenía entonces
bueno aquí usamos mucho las en méxico se
usaron mucho las copas grandes las más
anchas para crear vinos tuvimos acción
de restaurantes también había muchos
chefs hay tuvimos música todo el día
pueden ver los vídeos y las fotografías
en mi página www.lan.com está diciendo
quiere decir que el entorno es
importante a la hora de tomar el vino
esto no solamente el vino como tal
[Música]
acompañado con lo mismo que yo me tomé
un vino con nosotros
brindis porque se acaba de jubilar mi
esposa pero el chavo el miércoles
para este tipo de expediciones
le compré a mi marido un biólogo
mexicano italiano y está naciendo en
méxico de verdad vinos increíbles cuando
tú tienes un mensaje si ya tenemos a
nuestros fieles oyentes escucha veedores
que están en línea daniel camporini y
luis balderas está jose el julio
gonzález dorta no se josé julio desde
donde no se nos escucha viendo daniel
camporini dice saludos desde bailes otra
vez viajando en colectivo porque la
semana pasada pues sirve en el colectivo
y estaba escuchando
nuestro programa luis balderas dice
saludos desde chile amigos de radio
canadá internacional daniel camporini
agrega nuevamente pro por ti pierde
intacta porque pierden tiempo con el
fútbol pasan cosas más importantes y
después agrega si es por qatar vino yo
merezco más de un diploma muchas gracias
daniel césar rodríguez charlize desde
bogotá nos envía un saludo y danielle
camporini vuelve nuevamente y nos dice
el cabernet o el torrontés argentinos
son excelentes tenemos también a nuestro
querido amigo leonardo y colega leonardo
gimeno que está en línea y está
escuchando no saca entonces un saludo
leo aquí estamos al pie del cañón
nosotros de ser más tranquilo con la
victoria de uruguay esta mañana bueno y
los docentes pueden haber escuchado ya
el fluido del vino vertiéndose en las
costas
y que lo que porque has traído vinos
aquí para probar
esto no se puede solamente hablar del
vino tiene que experimentar y qué es lo
que ha servido que es lo que ha traído
susana para probar he comenzado con un
salva y salva es una bodega española
porque comienzo con un español porque
sin españa méxico no tendría viñas
américa no tendríamos viñas así de fácil
entonces ijalba es una es una bodega
que trabaja en bio envío que lo que
quiero decir es que vamos a hacer van a
hacer todo lo posible porque hacerlo lo
más natural posible
- menos químicos o nada de químicos
aquí el productor bernardo robin
este vino está el fulano el fular es la
presión para extraer el jugo entonces
este vino está hecho el fular como
siempre con los pies descalzos y en unas
grandes sí sí sí exactamente es 80%
tempranillo 20% gracia no gracias no es
una cepa bien española que le daba la
gracia a la rioja por eso se llama
gracias y estoy motivado en el lugar
mismo material en que en quebec
y vamos a encontrar bueno aquí los
invitó a degustar lo que vamos a
intentar entonces
vamos a encontrar este
un vino bien interesante yo encuentro 00
en la nariz frutas rojas frescas como la
fresa la cereza
los taninos ahorita que yo lo probé
están bien presentes están enrollados
como veremos aquí y la vamos a probarlo
la persistencia que no encontraremos muy
bien
gracias
y la acidez
está ahí la fruta y los taninos están
presentes ahorita que lo colocan antes
de servirlo la persistencia es tan larga
y está sólido hasta el final utilizado
eso de la persistencia larga es un
indicador del vino bueno mira hay vinos
vamos a encontrar muchos vinos que tú lo
tomas y 23 segundos y ya desapareció
trabajo
y pues qué lástima jaja
no no no es que sea una mala calidad
pero mientras más larga hasta la
persistencia mejor es como los perfumes
hay personas que se suelen 15 minutos y
otros que duran sí exactamente dan la
posibilidad de renovarlo con más
frecuencia sí pero fíjate que por
ejemplo aquí nos da la oportunidad de
tomar nuestra copa más tranquilamente y
mientras te estoy hablando y sigue aquí
me vino es un buen vino para qué para
qué situaciones dirías tú bueno
para esta situación por ejemplo para ir
con una paella para ir con el jamón
serrano para ir con la charcutería para
ir con carnes rojas para la barrica
y qué le dirías tú susana a un argentino
por ejemplo a nuestro colega vivo a
nuestro amigo daniel camporini que dice
acá en argentina hay muchas bodegas
boutique con producción limitada pero de
muy buena calidad y él es un conocedor
del vino que le diría de para este vino
español si los argentinos pues son
bastante como diría yo mi estimado
laborda tradicionales así que con muchos
consumidores de vinos argentinos
bueno produce una buena producción
exacto y bueno como lo podríamos dejar
para que vayan hacia un abismo español
digamos pues para el tempranillo
no tenemos tempranillos en argentina hay
mucho malbec
sí sí como esto pero quiero probar algo
español con un tempranillo con bastante
vinos españoles chilenos
necesitaríamos efectivamente no
solamente vinos argentinos
[Risas]
me dio ganas de tomar un vino esta noche
luego del trabajo es rico es amplio está
bien sólido bien presente que tiene el
productor además muy elegante
entonces si quieres un vino español él
ijalba esta noche para tu copa de vino
después del trabajo volvamos a hacer una
pequeña pausa y ya continuamos con el
vino con el mundial y con esta
conversación y por supuesto con las
copas de por medio
[Música]
y otro evento en el que participaste
susana lo dijimos al comienzo fue la
elección del mejor su medida de américa
en un evento que se llevó a cabo aquí en
la ciudad de montreal entre el 22 y el
24 de mayo de que se trató este evento
en particular la elección de el mejor
súmele de américa bueno es un evento que
está organizado por la asociación de
sommeliers e internacional con la ayuda
también de la asociación panamericana la
asociación panamericana de sommeliers o
la asociación internacional tiene como
objetivo dar la formación constante a
los sommeliers y la panamericana de
hacer los concursos también entonces
y que ve que es fuerte que ve que es
fuerte en cuestión de vinos e impresión
de essam el-erian y una producción de
vino importante no pero tiene muchas
formaciones sí pero canadá si tiene una
producción bien importante muy rica
el vino de ellas entonces que toman
verdaderamente muy en serio lo que es la
sommellerie ah bueno entonces este año
el anfitrión fue que a nada entonces el
primero está el concurso del mejor de
somalia de quebec el mejor familiar de
canadá y entonces el mejor sommelier de
américa
y entonces de aquí el ganador se va al
mejor sommelier del mundo mundial
otro mundial mundial y bueno verdad que
través que es que ve cuál línea no el
segundo lugar
en mundial y el islam ya ganó el quinto
lugar
sí sí sí son todos estos fuertes en sí y
hay más sommelier reconocidos aquí en
quiero y cuando se revisa el torneo
mundial para elegir al mini mejor del
mundo no tengo la fecha
[Música]
pero el de mejor sommelier de américa es
cada tres años otros cada tres años lo
hacemos y bueno decimos que este año
tocó aquí en canadá
en quebec en montreal aquí y bueno en
este tipo de eventos
si el examen es escrito y verbal
entonces se habla desde geografía el
tipo de suelos de suelos por supuesto
las bodegas también si se habla mucho de
las bodegas evidentemente el tipo de
verificación el tipo de vino
la práctica se hace la práctica se sirve
vino se hacen degustaciones a ciegas
y cuando viene ya la final se hace el
examen práctico frente a público susana
tuvo hablas acaba de mencionar la
degustación a ciegas que es la
degustación a ciegas bueno yo tengo una
botella de vino la cubro la cierva y
adivina que de dónde viene el enlace
para adivinar de qué se trata
alguien solamente cantando una copa de
vino es decir quien ha producido ese
vino
porque bueno vas conociendo los
productores de tanto que catas vas
conociendo el productor y así el aceite
tipo de vinos y si si se llega por
supuesto y entonces bueno
usted es el instituto de turismo y de
hotelería de quebec también está
involucrado mucho mucho está muy fuerte
apoyando la gastronomía y la sommellerie
a aquí en quebec cuya sede estaba muy
cerca de aquí sí sí sí exactamente y
bueno en los finalistas fueron eran tres
y entonces la decisión se examen
práctico en un teatro frente al público
y bueno la final fue el tercer lugar fue
cardinal de canadá aquí lo tengo martín
bruno de argentina
argentino argentino y primer lugar
pierre alexis canadá
argentina y entre entrenos
también está hablando de argentinos dice
daniel camporini al malbec lo rescatamos
en argentina el mundo lo rechazaba tú
qué dices de todos sanos bueno sabemos
que el mal ver bien era francia y es
verdad que llegó a argentina y llegó por
la familia catena por la familia catena
que plantó la primera viña de malbec
aquí al malbec le gustó el terruño el
terroir donde es todo el país le gustó
el clima y se dio bien pero chávez se ha
desarrollado una variedad propia y
malbec sí sí sí sí la diferencia en que
el malbec que aquel que llegó de francia
el malbec de francia yo lo siento más
e intenso en nariz
y lo encuentro en boca más denso más
constante
más récords
y el malbec de argentina yo lo encuentro
yo lo encuentro me atrevo a decir con
todo respeto con un poco más de alcohol
tenemos mucho sol es lógico y lo
encuentro más este más fácil a beber si
para acompañarlo suave no es más fácil
a ver a mis colegas rufo valència y
pocos barrios han tenido ya la suerte de
que tú le ha servido otros vinos también
lo tienes aquí
aprovechó ese momento de celo de mi
estimado luis laborda para luis balderas
dice que buenas indicaciones para probar
un buen vino acá en chile y en nuestra
zona existen viñas como casa marín
ahí está el productor del que tú
hablabas casa marina la importancia del
productor no entonces luis balderas nos
dice tenemos y existen viñas como casa
marina de la localidad de cartagena que
incluso han ganado premios
internacionales
susana este otro vino cuna de tierra
desde aquí eso diferencia del anterior
que probamos el grijalva bueno uno es
mexicano
dicho con mucho orgullo yo estoy bien
orgullosa de lo que bien méxico estoy
orgullosa de verdad glamoroso evento del
amoroso
si es cuna de tierra 2016 es de
guanajuato de mi estado de donde yo
vengo muy bien y más azucarado te parece
a mí también me pareció más dulce no
usar el término azucarado pero sí dulce
puede ser o no para ustedes
[Risas]
quiere decir un vino tiene distintos sus
sabores según quien lo cante no es el
vino es el paladar para los genes la
historia me imagino que cada persona del
mismo color del mismo color no lo ve de
la misma forma dos personas no por
supuesto que no esfuerzo por eso todos
los vinos son buenos no porque un vino
sea ligero
es la gama de vinos de iniciación para
mí pero a lo mejor tú fumas te antes a
lo mejor tú tomaste café antes quizás tú
tomaste una cerveza antes no dependiendo
entonces del gusto que el paladar tenga
antes de la de qatar en fin antes de
probar las cosas
[Música]
y cuál es la mejor forma entonces susana
de preparar el paladar cuando vas a
catar cuando vas a degustar un vino sin
comida a la hora antes del mediodía y
cuando tienes hambre ahí está
caramba pero no acaba mareado súper
rápido no es que no te lo tomas los
coupés simplemente
se trata de tomar de 85 bodegas en
méxico ya que no había no no lo hicimos
con gusto no imagínate no habría las la
tercera ya estás haciendo tu día normal
pero volvemos este orgullo mexicano pero
conquistas sobresaliendo méxico en
relación a los vinos ya están los vinos
mucho más estructurados más densos en
guanajuato
hay productos de san luis potosí
guaino increíble un gewürztraminer de
san luis potosí de baja de baja
california en el norte bueno estamos
cerca de la californiano entonces ahí
hay muchos viñedos
pero hay viñedos y viñedos y los que yo
provee die no no no de verdad qué
orgullo en querétaro pero el bus
terminar es dulce el clúster es una es
una cepa que se caracteriza mucho por
las flores es muy muy muy floral en la a
nadie se nos faltó es muy intenso el
aroma de los tomas y es muy al tercio
pelado
y bueno hay que buscar miner como el que
yo tomé ayer
con una buena acidez en las flores
al punto al punto que ni más ni menos
tanto en olfato como en gusto no meta
piso la boca la lengua lo que me
permitió probar el siguiente sin que
interviniera el que vuestra miner
y mucho aroma aroma pertenencia para mí
el agua o si es un vino muy femenino ha
sido muy femeninos y sí muy femenina
porque por perfumado perfume si es y
perfumada flores lo cual no quiere decir
que sea un vino que esté dirigido
solamente de consumo femenino no por
supuesto que no
términos que son solamente para mujeres
o vinos que son solamente para hombres
no no yo no lo creo así que no lo creo
así pero es verdad que
se toma mucho blanco en las mujeres
porque las mujeres prefieren el blanco
si es verdad porque el rojo normalmente
nos va a dar los taninos entonces lo
encuentras y si me permiten la expresión
como más agresivo
como más agresiva ya blanca además vamos
a decir a esta ligera más perfumado muy
bien
solamente decir daniel camporini dice
falta el queso hay que tratar y después
agrega la bodega geithner de mendoza
tiene la cava a 30 metros y allí vi el
malbec de 1973
ya volvemos la mente es una muy breve
recomendación de nuestros oyentes
aquí les habla marco castillo productor
músico brasileño que vive en winnipeg y
los invito a escuchar canadá en las
américas café de la radio canadá
internacional en la web
bueno antes de seguir hablando de vinos
los invito pablo y rufo a presentar los
temas que la sección ha estado
trabajando durante esta última semana
aquellos temas que destacamos entre los
otros que hemos producido pero que les
recomendamos a nuestros a nuestro
público consultar ver consumir leer
mirar en prioridad una historia muy
canadiense quiero recomendarles les
invito a conocer a alphonse davids
alfonso davis un joven de 16 a 17 años
ahora que a los 16 años
fue ese fue el jugador más joven en la
selección canadiense anotó dos
fantásticos goles en julio del año
pasado en lhasa en la terna torneo de la
concacaf a contra la güera francesa y en
moscú el miércoles poco antes de que se
anuncie qué país es o qué país iba a ser
la sede del mundial 2026
cada país tenía 15 tenía un 15 minutos
para hacer su presentación entonces
canadá escogió como como abogado como
como presentador de la propuesta
canadiense a este joven de 17 años de
origen africano nacido en un campo de
refugiados en en ghana y sus padres
huyeron de la segunda guerra civil en
liberia y él decía justamente que era
había llegado a los 5 años a canadá y
que él ahora era un muy curioso
canadiense y que su sueño había sido
llegar a la selección canadiense y que
su sueño también quizá más grande
jugar en su propia ciudad de edmonton y
decía así creada me aceptó a mí así
también les va a aceptar a ustedes y es
un jugador que juega actualmente para el
equipo whitecaps de vancouver entonces
una historia típicamente canadiense un
refugiado que llega que nada y llegas a
la selección canadiense excelente
jugador y sus sueños además en vías de
cumplirse porque el montón es una gracia
de propuestas para el mundial 2026 por
el lado canario exactamente así que y un
jugador sobre el cual además el fútbol
caliente tiene grandes esperanzas para
poder volver a los escenarios
internacionales porque la última vez que
que nada participó en el mundial fue en
1986 así que algo hace ya sí 1986 1 y
entonces alfonso alfonso' davis una
promesa del fútbol canadiense un
refugiado canadiense miembro de acción
canadiense y sobre quién hay muchas
esperanzas en el futuro última
participación canadiense en un mundial
entonces se dio en territorio mexicano y
ahora qué
mundial 2026 va a ser bien llevado a
cabo por tres países entre ellos méxico
méxico eeuu y canadá
buena buena posibilidad para que canadá
vuelva entonces a demostrar su fortaleza
eso fue lo que dijo ya sentido de que
efectivamente cada país tendrá un equipo
cada país tendrá su equipo en la
competición así que esperemos que pueda
ir un poco lejos esta vez que nada
justamente con esta nueva generación de
futbolistas que viene injustamente
muchos de la inmigración basta ver la
selección estadounidense por ejemplo
compuesta o la selección francesa son
selecciones mundiales que son resultado
de las migraciones y lo interesante es
que cuando el jugador hace bien lo hace
bien
johnson descubre que convirtió que
consumido sustancias indebidas
el jamaicano
[Risas]
bueno está ayer este este jueves
un organismo de defensa donde ecologista
exacto equipo de defensa del medio
ambiente sacó un informe e hizo público
un informe sobre el estado de la
seguridad de los oleoductos en canadá y
de acuerdo con ese informe pues el
estado de los oleoductos es lamentable
es
en un momento en que hay toda una
controversia como ya sabemos y ya hemos
hablado aquí en estos micrófonos sobre
los oleoductos y sobre todo uno en
particular kinder morgan en columbia
británica donde los pueblos indígenas se
oponen a este a que se extienda el
oleoducto que saldría desde la provincia
de alberta hasta la provincia de
columbia británica y sabemos que alberto
como bolivia no tiene salida al mar pero
sueño tiroides pero en bolivia sueña
albertano no tiene absolutamente ninguna
perspectiva entonces sabemos también que
alberto es una provincia productora
exclusivamente de petróleo su economía
depende de su producción petrolera
entonces toda la economía depende de la
exportación del petróleo y para ir a
buscar nuevos mercados tienen que
utilizar los oleoductos para llevarlos
si quiere enviarlo
asia oa cualquier otro lugar distinto a
eeuu tiene que tener una salida al mar
entonces él hay este oleoducto de kinder
morgan que sale desde alberta y se va a
colombia británica que es muy
cuestionado y la gente pues sobre todo
la gente de columbia británica no quiere
este oleoducto no quiere que pase por
sus tierras y ha quedado toda una
controversia la controversia aumentó
todavía más cuando no hace mucho el
primer ministro de canadá descentrado
dijo que o mejor dicho no dijo compró el
oleoducto kinder morgan por algo así
como 4 mil 500 millones de dólares
dentro de nuestro nuestro dinero no sea
dinero no es desde el que podríamos
invertir por ejemplo en vino
pero que se invirtió en la compra de
este producto entonces el hecho que x
tersa que en este momento su informe
sobre el estado de los oleoductos que
ese es el problema justamente con los
productos son los derrames sí sí la
contaminación del medio ambiente
entonces
y efectivamente lo que dice xt es que
están en un estado lamentable que las
autoridades responsables de supervisar
que la seguridad del transporte de los
petróleo por los oleoductos sea correcta
no lo hacen correctamente justamente y
que son la casi prácticamente las mismas
compañías las que asumen esa
responsabilidad de supervisar entonces
es como que no hay verdaderamente una
una supervisión correcta y el resultado
de eso es que hay muchos oleoductos que
pasan por encima de corrientes de agua
que están en mal estado y que se teme
que en un momento dado si hay un derrame
haya un desastre bastante diario en pos
del negocio entonces se ponga en riesgo
la salud a la salud y geografía de la
población entre otras cosas lo que dice
quitar es que si se produce un derrame
podría de alguna forma poner en peligro
el peligro digo ya el vino está haciendo
efecto
el peligro el abastecimiento en agua
potable en el oeste de la isla de
montreal entonces pues ese es lo que yo
invitaría pues a nuestros oyentes a ver
a escuchar este reportaje que habla de
lo que acabo de decir y de mucho más con
respecto a la seguridad de los
oleoductos en canadá y en que ve que en
particular perfecto y pasando de un
derrame potencial de petróleo o algo
como puede cerrar un poco la idea
susana este último vino que tú tienes
aquí de qué se trata bueno es un vino
italiano no sé si es un vino italiano
tenuta san antonio monte garbí
valpolicella en rivas o que es un repaso
porque italiano porque este año italia
es el país invitado de la gran
degustación en montreal
este y este esta cantina con ledesma
damián italiana esta cantina
pertenece a la familia histórica es una
familia de es un grupo
es una familia italiana que son
diferentes cantinas que bueno aquí el
objetivo para ellos es guardar y
preservar el método de elaboración y
tradición de la marrón entonces denota
san antonio pertenece a este grupo que
es la familia histórica pero que les
parece un mexicano
mexicano una gran sorpresa ver
justamente bueno yo soy un amateur del
vino así que lo que encuentro es que no
es ese vino joven que ha sido digamos
hecho con más con buena voluntad que con
talento y lo encuentre mucho más más
estable más más más más duro si se puede
sí sí sí mucha experiencia y porque
acabo de marcar un gol tirándose 1 a 0
si salud
y precisamente con ese gol que acaba de
marcar irán vamos ya cerrando nuestro
programa
yo quería agregar simplemente de que me
parecieron muy buenos los tres vinos y
muy distintos
en el sabor quiere decir lo que quiero
decir yo es que el degustando cada uno
de esos vinos yo que no soy nada
conocedor de vinos pude ver una
diferencia digamos en la calidad porque
mi mano son todos buenos pero en el
gusto y en el sabor y los tres son secos
fue un autogol
entonces un minuto al mundial le vamos a
dedicar menos tiempo del que pensábamos
pero con el vino si no fue casi todo el
programa y creo que justificadamente ha
comenzado el mundial de rusia
el primer partido fue el más agua el que
tuvo un score más abultado de rusia le
ganó a arabia saudita por 5 a 0 dando
una especie de sorpresa en el partido
inaugural hoy más temprano uruguay
venció por 1 a 0 a egipto y en este
momento estamos viendo en las pantallas
que marruecos pierde por 0 a 1 ante irán
según nos dijo grupos de 1 lo vi no lo
tenía decisivo el defensa trató de sacar
la pelota con cabeza por el lado con un
gol en contra cuáles son sus
predicciones para este mundial
yo en mi percepción y césar augusto
rodríguez charlie desde bogotá colombia
que dice hasta qué punto es bueno tomar
vino bajo estos conceptos de degustarlo
de esta forma quizás dejamos la pregunta
y no tenemos tiempo para la respuesta te
regresamos con la respuesta a la semana
próxima
obligaciones para mundial quien gana
este mundial kindle al mundial de
velocidad producción
es muy temprano para decir yo creo que
con un poco más de vino podría aventurar
mails pero alguna alguna selección que
hayas visto como mejor perfilada para
este torneo bueno en españa tiene tiene
mucha experiencia pero había que ver por
ejemplo acudir a españa en este momento
si realmente bueno la historia demuestra
que cuando hacen europa es un equipo
europeo el que gana aunque ha habido ha
habido excepciones a esa regla pero
habría que ver como no he visto jugar a
los otros a las selecciones europeas los
rusos
en portugal español va a dar una idea de
más o menos cómo se perfilan esos dos
equipos muy bien susana le ponen las
cartas a méxico
esta selección de méxico hace un buen
papel en el mundial ya me voy con su
bajo bueno yo no me arriesgo todavía con
él
el finalista pero yo diría que en
cuartos de finales se podría encontrar
colombia alemania brasil y
colombia alemania y brasil
y que más de argentina tú crees
tengo que reconocer que en esta ocasión
argentina me motiva bastante poco no he
visto la selección argentina que me
gustaría ver llegando a este mundial y
lamentablemente no nos quedó más tiempo
le prometemos por una próxima
conversación futbolera mundialista y con
vino de por medio porque no habrá un
poco el tema este de la candidatura ya
aceptada la denominación de eeuu canadá
y méxico para lo que va a ser el primer
mundial tripartito que va a tener tres
partidos inaugurales uno en cada país
y sí sí eso lo ha dicho ya la fifa de
aquí a ocho años pero como eso está
todavía por hacer y nos vamos entonces
con un poco de música que viene bien
para el caso se llama el tema que
estamos escuchando vino de danilo de que
es de el músico canadiense allan
freidzon es todo por hoy
muchísimas gracias por haber estado allí
despedimos a todos los que nos siguen
por todos los medios disponibles y será
entonces hasta la próxima a dios gracias
conocer que en esta ocasión argentina me
motiva bastante porque no he visto la
selección argentina que me gustaría ver
siga
este mundial y lamentablemente no nos
quedó más tiempo le prometemos por una
próxima conversación futbolera
mundialista y con vino de por medio
porque no habrá un poco el tema este de
la candidatura ya aceptada la nominación
de eeuu canadá y méxico para lo que va a
ser el primer mundial